matt's in orlando hey man how are you
hey i'm good how are you better than i
deserve sir how can i help
thank you so much for taking my call um
i've been listening and watching you for
about six months or so and my wife
actually introduced me to the debt
snowball
a few years ago but she didn't tell me
the rest of the plan
and now that i'm all invested i'm ready
to go i'm ready to get it done
pay off our debt and create a better
future
she's pulling back she doesn't want to
do it
and i may have come on too strong i may
have said you know we're getting rid of
the car
we're selling all this so chris if he
thinks he might have what do you think
the probability is that he was
uh probably about a hundred point twenty
seven nine nine nine percent
you scared her matt you know you done
scared her
off buddy you scared her buddy
you're selling cars purses bracelets
hold on a minute
hold on hey what got her excited about
it to begin with
why did she tell you about the debt
snowball
uh well uh that time i think we're in
about
a hundred and thirty thousand
worth and um
i ended up as you make
may be able to tell i'm kind of an
extreme person so when she started
telling me about it i said well i'll
just sell my truck i have a company
truck anyway
i don't need it so i got rid of it and i
brought us down to a hundred thousand
and um then she kind of saw where i was
headed with all of it she said okay
never mind right she got scared and
the the reality is is i would go back
and ask her
honey when you first mentioned the death
snowball to me what was the motivation
what was the thing that got you going on
this
and what happened is you got in the bus
and started driving
and you left her back at the house
you've started the journey and she's
back there standing with her book bag
waiting and so what you need to do is
back up
and go back and reconnect so you guys
can gain alignment together on this
thing
it's got to be a we thing that you're
doing not a you thing
and so getting her a chance to get back
connected to communicate
and you're hearing her as much as you're
talking to her
i think we'll help you guys get back on
this plan together if your intensity
becomes
as a couple 9 out of 10 where
currently you are 12 out of 10 and she's
2 out of 10.
you'll be better off in other words if
you'll slow down just a little bit
yeah and get her on board you're going
to move faster overall
right and so yeah you just can't
um you you've already self-diagnosed
before you called
you knew what to do right pretty much
it's just it's just that you want to go
you just want to go wide open you just
want to push down on the
pedaling just go completely wide open
and uh instead chris is telling you put
it in reverse
go back and pick her up and then move
forward a step at a time
get agreement on each thing instead of
like
hey sold my truck today you know um
that just you know she you just scared
her to death yeah you did
without a doubt but i'm gonna tell you
this i love your commitment matt
and i love how you go head down but i
just want you to join hands with your
spouse and you guys go in unison
yeah it's a good idea to kind of talk
through this for a second because what
he's
experiencing is not that unusual um it's
pretty typically um i would guess
more than half the time i'm just gonna
pick out a number i'm making that
percentage up
more than 50 percent of the time that
someone starts with ramsey plus they get
into financial peace university or they
they watch the reset event from january
that you and i and rachel and craig
groschel did
or they read the total money makeover
wherever it is they get this new
information
and it's not unusual for one spouse
to run off and get all excited and just
run on down the road and then go oh wait
i left my spouse back there oh god i
left the kid back at the gas station i
got to go back you know
we're in such a big hurry that we lost
ground
because you don't and so you're much
better off and really here
from having done this for 30 years and
you've been around it for 20
is um people get
further moving slower together
yes than they do moving super fast
and leave one behind that's right
because you end up with all these fits
and starts
and conflict that ultimately creates
friction and slows everything down
it really does and what i've seen too
from coaching people and working with
couples
is the one that has slowed down is
typically fearful of what they're going
to have to give up
but if they feel like they've got to say
yes if their voice is being heard
yes their vote counts at the budget
committee meeting that's right
if your vote doesn't count the budget
committee meeting you have a right to
dig your heels in
and say wait i gotta vote here yeah i
don't think we ought to do that
and uh i mean there's two pretty
substantial financial issues sitting on
the table at the ramsey house right now
that we're not in agreement on
and what we do is and we don't move
until we get agreement
and so you know either one of us can
just completely bring whatever the item
is to a
screeching halt until we get agreement
on that and it can be a
a large gift and a charitable donation
to a ministry
and one of us doesn't feel comfortable
with it the gift size or the ministry or
whatever
one of us doesn't feel comfortable with
it or it can be a purchase it could be
an
investment um it could be anything but i
mean you know
we just don't move forward because every
time we move forward without the other
one
the cost is greater than the joy that
would have come
from that step that we were getting
ready to take and so we just have to
wait and
god it's so freaking frustrating it's
just
would you just get this right in your
head because i can make a decision in
about 13 seconds yeah about 10.
and um and if that's wrong i'll just
make another one that's exactly right so
but
uh but you know and sharon needs to
process stuff
and process stuff she got feelings well
i don't have any of those i gave them up
you found two yeah i gave them up for
lent
you know i'm laughing but it's true it
is true
that is true oh well we're glad you're
here because you're huggable
you're just huggable that's what you are
big scary christopher
oh stop that